two DUIs in a row ridiculously high
blood alcohol contents looking at jail
time a precipice of of getting fired
chaotic disaster that I weathered very
much linked to my alcoholism I didn't
know what was going on I started to
drink more and more and more and it was
really hard for me to accept that that
meant I was an alcoholic I woke up with
the worst hangover alcohol used to be
this social thing I used to connect with
people and go out had now become
something I did nightly alone by myself
you know those situations created such a
deep level of Shame inside of me that I
wasn't able to shake alcohol in the wake
of those experiences